liars who tell them and rush limbaugh is
a big fat idiot
the latest bestseller from the radio
host is the truth with jokes he spoke
about it Wednesday at the Jimmy Carter
librarian Museum in Atlanta for an hour
ten minutes one of the things that to me
is one of the most fun jobs I have here
at the Carter Center is is working with
authors we have some wonderful authors
that come in it's just one of many
things we do if you haven't had a chance
to see one of our exhibits the first
lady's exhibit there are brochures out
there I'd be sure and pick up a brochure
it is a fabulous exhibit you're going to
want to see it it just dresses it's
China it's jewelry of first lady it's
going back to Martha Washington it is
really good you're really going to want
to see it tonight the focus though is
authors and we're fortunate and having
Al Franken here because of partner we
have Frank Rees and a cappella books and
the Georgia Center for the books are
really great organizations that that
helped bring authors so that you and I
can hear them to introduce Al Franken
here's Frank Reese from acapella books
[Applause]
thanks Stephanie you know for a Jewish
kid who grew up in the 70s and never
having a date so that he was home
watching TV every Saturday night from
1975 to 1980 introducing Al Franken is a
tremendous thrill of course we've all
enjoyed Al Franken's work for decades
but since he left Saturday Night Live in
1995 and focused his biting satire on
the rightward drift of our political
landscape his work has become even more
than ever more vital than ever and as
the excitement surrounding this event
indicates he's really become a true
American Hero we in Atlanta can stake a
small claim on mr. Franklin's career
shift because it was in our city during
the Democratic National Convention in
1988 that he debuted as a political
analyst on CNN after that he melded his
insights and humor in the groundbreaking
work he did for Comedy Central and from
there it was to the top of the New York
Times bestseller list first with Rush
Limbaugh is a big fat idiot
and then lies and the lying Liars who
tell them and tonight he'll share with
this his third New York Times number-one
bestseller the truth with jokes
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Al Franken
when
[Applause]
thank you so on the way over here I
remembered something rush limbaugh we
have Manar we play a monarch show every
once a while we usually have a Ditto
head there's a friend of mine from high
school who listens to Russia all the
time and we play rush for them and then
my friend NASA defend would rush set and
usually it's just it's usually just a
lie you know and then my friend goes
okay but the bigger point is true or
something like that and we've been doing
this for a year and a half my friend
hasn't changed too much but here because
that came the Carter Center and I got my
computer here and has a Google Desktop
and I got my all my scripts here so this
I want to play this for you because I'm
so honored to be here at the Carter
Center so this is when Jimmy Carter won
the Nobel and this is what Rush Limbaugh
said I'll try to do mine Limbaugh Jimmy
Carter can't stand being a limelight
because he knows he's nothing anymore
he knows he knows he doesn't amount to
anything he knows that the Nobel Prize
is fraudulent I don't know how he sleeps
at night
Galgo down I said the coverage you get
he gets of courses as though he's a
credible spokesman because the
anti-american left the blame America
first crowd loves to hearing from these
empty brain Neanderthals like Jimmy
Carter would somebody point to me we're
in the third world Jimmy Carter had made
a difference for the positive you see
it's typical liberalism all you have to
do is act like you care you know have a
couple meetings so I played this remark
and I said okay mark
how about guinea worm infections down 99
percent in 20 African and Asian
countries it's been a focus of the
Carter Center since it launched and
cases of head of anywhere infections
have declined and getting one of
infections are these horrible things
they come out of your body
you can't break them because you get
gangrene so you have to wrap them around
I mean and they cause like polio they've
gone cases of decline from 3.5 million
to fifteen thousand five hundred
[Applause]
in 1995 Carter negotiated a two-month
Sudanese ceasefire allowing leaders and
citizens of Sudan to initiate efforts to
eradicate guinea worm disease prevent
river blindness and immunize children
against polio and other diseases in 1987
the Carter Center convinced Merck
a fortune 500 company to donate the drug
Mectizan where as long as might be
needed to control river blindness in
Africa the campaign prevented 600,000
cases of river blindness assured that
some 18 million children in a twenty
country area will never get the disease
the center distributes 20 million pills
a year it goes on and on actually at one
point mark said okay you can stop now I
said no no no I want to continue I want
to continue because he wanted to know
one person tell me where in the third
world he's done anything for the
positive this is why I wrote rush
limbaugh of the big fat idiot and
[Applause]
Carr Center also has people have asked
me why that title by the way Rush
Limbaugh's big fat idiot and at the time
anyway Russia's very very fat so yeah
enormous huge huge fat fat fat fat me
just morbidly obese just team Norma's
Lee fat with a huge huge gut and and a
big fat ass he was this the Carter
centers also had a has also had
successful health programs to voters the
treatment of you might have to help me
out here
skills to my office might shift so my at
myiasis okay which is the second most
devastating parasitic disease in
tropical countries after malaria
lymphatic full area is the farming
parasitic disease in trachoma a
preventable cause of blindness beyond
pine disease directly Carter has tried
to attack one of the causes malnutrition
working with the Safa calleb global 2000
agricultural program his health
introduced a crop called quality protein
maize to various countries notably Ghana
and actually that spread now to 15
sub-sahara African countries and then my
friends had stop stop and I Jimmy Carr
is a great guy it's just a great man
[Applause]
[Music]
today today is the 30th of November
president brought out his program I
guess what it was called the national
strategy for victory in Iraq as I was
called and it was I seem to bring out
two and a half years after we you don't
want to get that victory strategy out
there too soon I think I'm going over to
Iraq in about two weeks
I USO tour and it's my third honor it's
my honor to do it and my wife doesn't
like me doing it she says to me you know
you don't see Bill O'Reilly going on a
USO tour to Iraq and I say honey that's
not fair he has no talent and I actually
used that joke a lot anta it's a I bring
it I tried it out and once while Sean
Hannity was at the Democratic convention
we were on radio row and he he was kind
enough to sit down I can't believe I
said anything good about Sean Hannity
but he sat down to talk to me and and I
said the same thing I said because we
were talking about you know patriotism
or something and I said well you know I
do these USO tours my wife doesn't like
it she asked me you don't see Sean
Hannity going USO tours I said
definitely that's not fair he has no
talent and and handy said that's not
funny
and I said
and I said to him no it is it is fun you
know I said and let me explain why it's
funny because it sounds like I'm I'm
going to defend you but then I give you
a little bit that's why it's fun anyway
so I I love doing these USO tours
because it just means a lot to me and
it's also it's just nice it's something
I can you know something I can do but I
come back I got to say I come back a
little angry because I believe we were
misled into this war and I believe
deliberately and I believe that this war
has been fought in the worst way
possible
every step of the way I spoke at West
Point a few weeks ago and I did a kind
of far and I said you know I did some
USO jokes
no I was on their side but the the the
it was a lecture about the truth but no
no I'm sorry it was lecture about
freedom freedom has an annual lecture
the SOL finds stone lecture at West
Point I speak to I spoke to the junior
class of Cadets and I was about freedom
and I basically after get him laughing
and on my side I said you you can't have
freedom without the truth I've written
about a book called the truth with jokes
as the Dutch and the Swiss have proven
you can have freedom without jokes
but you can't have freedom without the
truth and the president lied us into
this war and then I went through it I
went through what the president said and
what the vice president said and by the
way should the vice president just just
not be allowed to talk anymore because
when did he say the intern season that
joe says last throws okay just stop
talking before the word there is no
doubt that saddam possessed some
stockpiles of WMD there's going to
planning to use against nations around
him and in our country no doubt means
something it means there's no doubt all
the intelligence I mean the the
president would try it out all the time
this thing about al Qaeda had been
trained in weapons in poisonous gas and
and biological and chemical weapons we
got that from some al Qaeda detainee
that the it turns out the Defense
Intelligence Agency said that the guy
was fabricating that was it it was okay
for the President to tell now if you say
by the way this is what Republicans are
down to now when you say well the
president lied they go I lied yeah and
then you start trotting out things like
like the Defense Intelligence well how
do you know he saw that what are you
saying are you saying that they didn't
give it to him
how do you know they gave it to him okay
so you're saying basically the president
they didn't give the president the
intelligence well he probably did but he
might not have read it now you know he
read it and you've got you guys always
say the president is is intellectually
lazy and doesn't read and can't retain
information which is it is it that or
did he lie it can't be both yeah it's
both I mean and and up the aluminum
tubes yeah I mean the whole thing is a
scared us into the war they were going
to pass a nuclear weapon on to al-qaeda
because of their close ties to al Qaeda
and al Qaeda was going to either al
Qaeda wiser or Iraq was with their
unmanned aerial vehicle which somehow is
going to get to the United States
because it had the right range of 12,000
miles and drop a nuclear bomb on us
because they Jim there's no doubt that
Saddam has reconstituted his nuclear
program yes there is that there was no
there's no nuclear program and what was
the evidence the only physical evidence
was were these aluminum tubes condi rice
these glulam tubes can't be used for
anything other than centrifuging uranium
the Colin Powell said the same thing I
was for the war because Colin Powell who
I trusted you know we have this
presumption in this country that the
president's going to tell us the truth
dumb me
I thought Colin Powell would tell the
truth memory he said at the beginning of
this thing and he's apologized for it he
has he said that all of these aren't
allegations these are all soundly
sourced and one point he starts talking
about the aluminum tubes and he says why
would these aluminum tubes be built with
such spot a fine specifications if they
weren't being used to centrifuge uranium
the smooth surface this anodized coating
they have anodized coating why would
they have anodized coating if they
weren't going to be used for nuclear
centrifuging uranium into weapons-grade
uranium I was watching this I went oh my
god they have anodized coating I don't
know what that is but it a must
he must be building a bomb because Colin
Powell is telling me they got anodized
coating a few months later conveniently
after we were at war Bart Gellman Walter
Pincus from the Washington Post went to
Oak Ridge Tennessee or talked to the guy
from Oak Ridge Tennessee who was the
father of centrifuging uranium and asked
him about the aluminum tubes now by this
time we had they hadn't found any
nuclear program and we knew there wasn't
the UN knew there wasn't a nuclear
program the IAD knew that or
International Atomic Energy Agency sorry
IEA but okay so they asked this guy
could these tubes The Washington Post
has could these tubes be used for
centrifuge in uranium they asked the
father of centrifuge and uranium and he
goes well no no they're too small and
this is what the energy analysts had
said they ought to all said this and so
when condi rice said there's no they
can't be used for anything else she was
lying because we all know I mean unlike
the president she can read I mean she
reads
[Applause]
and and then and then this guy said and
this is a paraphrase but he said
basically look they're too small but
even if they were you were able to
centrifuge rhenium with tubes this size
the first thing you'd have to do is mill
off all the anodized coating I didn't
see the speech today I was I did a radio
show today in Asheville North Carolina
and I was preparing for that preparing
for that by not hearing his speech but
we had George Packer on who's written a
great book which I can't believe I'm
saying this on books TV on c-span but
because I got a nonfiction hardcover out
but assassins at the gate is just an
essential book on Iraq and an Packer we
had he George's from The New Yorker and
we and he had seen a speech and just
basically kind of too little too late
and which is unfortunate we I don't know
what to do one of the first things that
I would like to see this president do in
order to for us to actually have a real
dialogue and this ain't going to happen
is for the president to hold himself and
his administration accountable for
what's happened so far
[Music]
and and that way and that way we could
like trust I mean it on asking to go on
TV and just tick off the mistakes he
made you know he and do it honestly just
say okay you know I deliberately misled
you into the war but we didn't think
you'd go to war unless you thought there
was a nuclear program so we kind of
cherry picked an over emphasized certain
things ignored of weil idea but I'm
sorry we I didn't send enough troops we
ignored general Shinseki the army chief
of staff and actually pretty much
intimidated the rest of the Pentagon by
firing him or you know essentially
announcing his retirement too quickly
that was an awful mistake a terrible
mistake not to send in so many troops
because we couldn't we couldn't secure
things like Oh explosive depots and and
and then also allowing the looting when
you know not giving orders stop looting
now all of this was covered in the
pre-war planning done by the State
Department and the CIA and the Army War
College all said the same thing send in
all these hundreds of thousands of
troops don't allow looting get the
electricity and gas up first I didn't
read it I I i I'm not a good reader I
can read I'm not a good reader and I
don't like long things the future of
Iraq project was I was fifteen hundred
pages I can read about a page a page
then it just starts repeating I can't I
start thinking I'm reading the same
thing over and over I can't read very
well I'm sorry I'm good at picking
people I'm smart I'm not it's not like
I'm dumb I'm a good people person I knew
Karl Rove right away was a was a
ruthless guy who would do anything to
get me elected to anything I did and
that he'd just lie all the time and
smear people I'm a good people person
but I'm sorry about this and then of
course the disbanding the Iraqi army
probably telling four hundred thousand
guys you're all fired
we're not going to pay you get lost and
take your weapons with you was probably
kind of stupid I admit that that was
just dumb that was dumb giving these no
bid contracts and and all these
contracts to Americans and not not over
doing any oversight 8.8 billion dollars
missing from the Coalition Provisional
Authority totally unaccounted for all
that money that wasn't spent getting up
the electricity going up the water
reconstructing the country employing
Iraqis alienated the Iraqi people and
fueled the insurgency and is killing our
guys I'm sorry I'm an idiot I I did that
oh and torturing people ah man that
turned out to backfire did you know that
that backfired and so anyway what I have
in mind is basically a six-hour speech
by the president admitting what he did
and I think that at the end of that
everyone would go like okay he's come
clean I trust him now I trust the
information I'm getting from them
there's the thing that I read some in
the this new document they sent out
their new strategic plan that they say
now we have two hundred thousand Iraqis
in the Iraqi army and whereas last year
we had ninety four last
member we had 94,000 that's what they
said in this document except last
February seven months before the last
September when they said ninety four
thousand Rumsfeld said there were two
hundred ten thousand when these guys
should just if they're going to lie to
us
just get your story straight it makes me
angry the book is the truth with jokes
it's a little I will admit it a little
bit more serious than my last book lies
in line wires which after all was about
how there isn't a liberal mainstream
media but there is a right-wing media
and so I spent a lot of it going after
Bill O'Reilly and Ann Coulter and
Hannity and and that is low-hanging
fruit for a comedian so
[Applause]
this book is really about its prescient
in a lot of ways this book I must say so
myself
and that is that when I was writing the
book there were actually people in this
country who still thought the president
was competent and and it
I think there's 30-some percent now who
do maybe and and also I write a lot in
the book about Jack Abramoff and Tom
DeLay and this incredibly corrupt
Congress and that is all coming to
fruition which is actually the book is
divided into three parts try to pretty
quickly because I want to read a chapter
is a short chapter the first part of the
book is called the triumph of evil and
it's about the election and it's it's
shows how Bush won and I bait it that's
in three parts fear which is 9/11 24/7
and conflating Iraq with 9/11 a smear
which is smearing Kerry and queers which
is you know the gay marriage thing
trying to exploit that I don't
understand how gay marriage threatens
heterosexual marriage
[Music]
you know III don't like walk down the
street see two gay guys together and go
to my wife you know honey that looks
kind of good
you know you know honey you don't like
watching football I'll bet you I could
find a guy who would marry me and on
Sundays we could watch football together
and then if I want to have sex I could
come home and have sex with you and she
says you don't understand how this works
and I was talking we're in Georgia and
so we're in Laos
I was talking to Newt Gingrich the other
day and I said to him I said new don't
you want for gay couples what you had
with your first wife don't you don't you
want that that bond that comes from an
oath of fidelity that you had with your
second wife don't you want that what
comes with with with with a lifelong
commitment that you may or may not have
with your third wife I don't know what's
going on there so I don't understand the
second part of the book is called the
seeds of collapse and it goes in the
schiavo and the social security stuff
and and the amazing corruption that
we're seeing in Congress and into Iraq
and this is is all happening and the
Republican Party now is ready to
collapse and we need to take back this
country but
but we're not going to do it unless we
prove that we deserve it and can take
and and and articulate a vision and
that's what I do in the third the third
chapter is called the resurrection of
hope and it's or the third part of the
book and it's a letter to my
grandchildren in the Year 2015
telling them about how some Americans a
lot of Americans stood up during this
dark period and took the country back
starts off dear Barack Hilary and Joe
the third my sons open and and then in
this letter we take over the house in
2006 we get subpoena power and so and
then in 2008 and we and we introduced
some legislation because the Senate is
50/50 and
Cheney has to cast tying bow tie
breaking votes but he just starts
cursing all the time and c-span actually
has to be asked to go on pay-per-view
just because c-span - anyway because
this Cheney's just swearing up a storm
the whole time then 2008 we take
everything in this and it's again it's
just it's a it's a fantasy it's ten
years from now but I get elected senator
from Minnesota and 2008 and
and and I I say in the book I don't
decide whether I'm running till 2007 but
I come in and a lot of people don't
realize this but the Congress comes in
the session about two weeks before the
inauguration
so I commanders in the Senate and I say
to my colleagues in the house and in the
Senate I said why don't we impeach bush
because we got it on you know he wasn't
peaceful and everyone says well why he's
only got two weeks left and I said well
because we can and I say you know what
better way to usher in a real era of
personal responsibility than by
impeaching bush and everyone gets sick
very excited so we have a quickie
impeachment and in fact in just a space
one afternoon a bush is impeached
convicted and starts drinking again but
he gets into recovery it has a happy
ending anyway
that sort of all here's what I want to
read this and I think that that actually
that when we take over it we're going to
do it on Values I think values and Jimmy
Carter can certainly talk to that so
this is a chapter called Al Franken
talks about God and you'll have to
excuse me now I think I can I've done
enough of these signings now that I get
through this without it's about my dad
so without tearing up or choking out and
but sometimes I do and just just know
this that I cry at a good mcdonald's
commercials
so don't worry if it's if I do that it's
fine I'm going to try to do I'm Jewish
thank you thank you so I suppose I'm not
really much of a position to argue the
Conservatives have hijacked Christianity
and I haven't read the New Testament
from cover to cover but from what I
understand if you cut out all the
passages in the Bible where Jesus talks
about the poor about helping out the
least among us if you can't cut out
every one of those passages you'd have
the perfect container the smuggle Rush
Limbaugh's drugs in my views about God
come from my dad he died 12 years ago of
lung cancer which brings me to a funny
story dad died at home my brother and I
both came back to Minnesota to be with
him and mom for what turned out to be
the last three weeks of his life about a
week before dad died we got a call from
when I by blacks who asked me if he
could come over and talk to him I
thought about it for a while and told
the rabbi that I didn't think so
dad knew he was dying he knew we knew he
was dying but we never discussed it as
such and I just didn't want dad to have
to talk about his death unless he
brought it up himself
a couple days later rabbi black called
again could he come over and comfort my
mother well mom was a total wreck by
that and if someone was able or capable
of giving her any comfort it would
certainly have been a relief for me and
my brother
sure rabbi so rabbi black came over and
sat in our living room with the three of
us for however long and I don't remember
thing he said other than would it be
okay if I could see your father
the thought instantly crossed my mind
that the comforting mom bit was just a
way for the rabbi to get his foot in the
door to get it dad but I felt guilty
immediately for even thinking this I was
kind of a wreck myself
I told the rabbi I checked with my dad
and went down the hall to his bedroom by
now dad was down to about 75 pounds and
extremely weak but he was still totally
on the ball I said to him dad
rabbi Black is here and he was wondering
if he could talk to you it took that a
moment to gather his breath and say well
I don't really know him rabbi black was
new to the temple then with a shrug in
his voice dad said but if he feels it'll
do him some good I laughed really hard
and dad smiled a happy satisfied smile
because the son had given him the best
gift you could receive in our house
laughed at his joke I went back to the
living room told rabbi black to dad but
seemed rabbi span about half an hour
were dead who died five days later
bye-bye black presided over dad's
memorial where I told thee if he feels
it'll do him some good story
everyone laughed especially rabbi black
it was until a few months ago that I
heard the rest of the story I was in
Albuquerque New Mexico where rabbi black
now has a congregation our radio show is
joining us southwest and I invited the
rabbi to be part of the audience before
the show we sat in a small office at the
National Hispanic cultural center and I
asked for a by black how his talk with
my dad had gone the rabbi smiled and
said oh he just tried to make me feel as
comfortable as possible
that was my dad Joe Franken was born in
1908 in New York City to immigrant
parents his dad my grandfather Otto
Franken died of tuberculosis when dad
was 16 so dad went to work and didn't
finish high school he never had much of
a career dad was a printing salesman for
the last 30 years of his working life
but everyone liked Joe Franklin he and
mom were married 53 years they bickered
sometimes maybe more than sometimes but
were completely devoted to each other
mom pretty much fell apart after he died
neither of my folks was particularly
observant but my dad liked going to
Temple mainly for him it was a social
thing he was an usher and he loved the
music and the sermons rabbi Shapiro the
rabbi he knew spoke from the Bema about
Jewish religious philosophy and the
requirement that Jews not only be just
but that we do justice
unlike mom dad was comfortable talking
with me about religion and God he
believed in God but not as an old man
with a long white beard sitting in
heaven many ways dad's views our view of
God was like our founding fathers not
Abraham Isaac and Jacob Thomas Jefferson
John Adams and James Madison were really
not Christian so much as dias to dad the
Bible meaning the Old Testament was not
to be taken literally woman evolved
along with man through natural selection
not from Adam's rib the work of God
could be found as our founders believed
in nature dad told me that he believed
nature which to him include humankind be
so beautiful so magnificent that there
had to be something behind it all that
was it that was dad's idea of God
something mind at all
it was no more or less complicated than
that for dad the rest of religion lay
and the ethical teachings of Judaism and
to the extent he had absorbed them of
any other faith Western Eastern or
whatever again not so different from our
founders and their famous correspondence
at the end of their lives Adams and
Jefferson wrote a lot about religion
when Adams concluded that his personal
Creed was quote contained in four short
words be
just and good Jefferson replied the
result of our fifty or sixty years of
religious reading in the forwards be
just and good is that in which all our
enquiries must end so if your definition
of traditional American religious value
starts with the founders you could say
my Jewish father's values were as
traditional as they get Jefferson of
course had sex with a slave which Dad
would have disapproved of mainly on the
slavery front
my conception of God is pretty much the
same as dads and like him I respect
other people's religious beliefs I know
they derive tremendous inspiration joy
and solace from their faith
I also expect others to respect my
beliefs that's also a traditional
American value I consider myself a very
fortunate person most of all because
I've been extremely lucky in my family
life even though my wife and I had not
been totally abstinent before getting
married
we will be celebrating our 30th wedding
anniversary a few weeks before this book
comes out how have I managed to stay
married for 30 years many of them happy
I credit fear my fear of being alone
also there's Franny's willing us to
tolerate me and of course we're a family
I'm not a big one for prayer unless you
consider counting your blessings as
praying I'm grateful every day for my
two unbelievably great kids please
indulge me in a moment of fatherly pride
here both my kids are smart happy funny
and kind those of you listened to my
radio show know I brag way too much on
my daughter Thomason and the fact that
she teaches third grade at an inner-city
public school in the Bronx she hates
when I do it and always ask me to stop
which makes me even more proud of how
modest kids she didn't get that for me
my son is Joe after my dad here's
another point of pride at Joe's high
school they give out one prize to a
graduating senior there are no academic
awards no valedictorian just a Billy
Ferrell award named for particularly
beloved student who died in a car
accident a number of years ago
essentially it's the mention of the
class award you know I'm telling you
this because the school presented Joe
with the honor of course I credit his
mom mostly you see when Joe is about
eight years old he was over another kids
house and the kids mom asked Joe why are
you such a nice guy Joe said I think it
is something
my grandfather his dad in heaven looking
down giving that smile he gave me when I
laughed at his joke I have no clue
actually I really doubt it but I know
he's part of me and a part of everyone
who loved him I think somewhere in there
is God pretty well
thank you okay we're going to thank you
you know the McDonald's commercial where
like they've hired a special person I
just cry I can't help okay let's open it
to questions and what you do is I guess
is there their microphones or something
or you can just you know if you can for
the recording we have a microphone over
here and a microphone over here and if
you can keep your questions short and as
questions so that we can get in as many
we'd like to do about 10 minutes worth
of questions before that all well I'll
stay here as long as you will okay well
longer okay little bit longer we have a
question over here please yeah hi al hi
Hey
speaking as somebody Jewish a Cohen all
right who also had a great time can you
speak up a little bit yes speaking as a
Cohen speaking as somebody else Jewish
she also had a great father and a great
mother and someone who is disgusted with
the fact that the neocons many of these
neo-cons who got us into iraq are jewish
I'm asking you as somebody who isn't
decided yet to be someone Jewish who
gets us out and decides we need to be
out not take our time not not miss how
deeply they are screwing with things now
getting into bed with the Iranians and
with the fundamentalist Islam assist so
it's getting deeper and uglier by the
day
so I'm asking you at because I'm Jewish
and I'm ashamed of Wolfowitz and the
rest of them to be a Jew who gets us out
of here and says let's get out now
thank you not a Joe Lieberman thank you
um okay look I'm ashamed of Wolfowitz
not because he's Jewish
just because he's a you know in America
he he you know when he was asked he was
testifying to a House subcommittee and
he was asked how many Americans had died
in Iraq and this other point we're about
728 Americans some some were very close
to that had died and he he didn't know
he said about 500 about 350 of those in
combat this is the Deputy Secretary of
Defense I mean I knew at the time these
guys don't care but you know there's
plenty of Gentiles to blame - I mean rum
Rumsfeld nah now and I come on come on
let me answer your question and I don't
just can't be a dialogue between me and
a Cohen
you know Rumsfeld sign killed-in-action
letters with an autopen and then when he
was asked about it they lied they'll lie
about that then they compared it was a
colonel hackworth did this and and and
and they they compared the letters to
families and it turned out yes he was
signing them with an autopen yes they
finally admitted it but the reason i
don't know what to do is my feeling is
is that we withdrew precipitously and
just cut and run and this is easy for me
to say because i i talked about my son
my son isn't there
i have no skin in the game so it's easy
for me to say but my fear is is that if
we just cut run now that it would been
the perfect war and since everything
would have been done wrong until
including the very end we shouldn't have
gone in but we're lied in we didn't send
enough guys in we didn't got we let them
loot we did everything wrong everything
wrong and then left
dishonorable i don't know if there is a
situation if there is a way out and if
someone can convince me that our very
presence there just makes things worse
and it's just going to be if there's no
no way out of this with honor and i'm
not talking about some odd stupid sense
of honor i'm talking about actually
trying to make the iraqis life not worse
than it was when we went there because
it is a mess you know they have you know
i don't have to tell you all the what's
going on there in terms of militias and
civil
or and torturing of Sunnis and Sunnis
killing she is and you know moqtada
al-sadr is on the ballot with just as
much as the Dawa party or the scary
party I mean it's it's we have been put
in this no-win situation and what I love
is we get we sort of get some from Bush
to to Democrats is like hey I got us in
there
I lied you in there I didn't send in
enough troops I allowed the looting I we
I tortured we tortured people we ran a
corrupt reconstruction effort that the
the Congress won't do any oversight on
we disbanded the military and let 4,000
guys with guns loose we didn't guard the
ammunition DEP depots I've done my job
now you tell me what to do come up with
the solution Democrats I mean I kind of
resent that and I don't know if I have a
right to do that but I don't know what
to do and I don't think is and and and
as someone who has a radio show and and
someone actually people look to me to
say what to do and I don't think it's
leadership to say what to do when you
don't know what to do and I don't think
we've been put in a pot and I think
we're in a no-win situation I think
we've been put there but I I am NOT
certain that withdrawing now and cutting
and running is the right thing to do and
I'm sorry I don't I don't know yeah I
guess I feel like the way that we got go
there you know how many members of the
Bush administration it takes to change a
lightbulb
do I know how many members of the Bush
administration takes to screw in a light
bulb well it's a trick question
throughout of light bulbs the trick
question there are no light bulbs are
out of light bulbs though they're out of
labels listen I here's a rule here's the
rule I'll I'll do the jokes that's just
that's the rule
I am I'm a school teaching we have
questions somewhere in between those
I'm affordable are we going to get a
third type of bag I'm a schoolteacher
and I've I don't have the opportunity to
listen to your radio show but I am proud
to say my wife and I made some strategic
emails to make sure certain cable
network began to care you again late at
night so my question is what do you
think historians will look back and say
about this decade and what do you think
they'll say about your role that you
played well will historians say about my
role well I think that if Doris Kearns
Goodwin lives long enough her book about
me will be called the courage to dare
I am I you know I hope and and and the
answer sort of is in the end of my book
in terms of what I'm hoping this decade
will end up like which is we have to and
and in it I lay out the issues that I
believe that Democrats got a coalesce
around and offer to the country and one
thing that I did in in doing my radio
show was I said I'm going to be on three
hours a day I got you know might as well
this might as well be a learning
experience so one of the things I've
learned is how central to everything
health care is and if you look at you
know like the bankruptcy bill this awful
bankruptcy bill that was passed this
year which by the way there was no
exemptions for anyone who join thank
Rupp because of a natural disaster that
was an amendment offered by Democrats
and then after Katrina Democrats came
back with a bill that would offer
exemptions to this bankruptcy bill from
people who had become bankrupt because
of Katrina and Republicans wouldn't let
it get into committee anyway
fifty percent people go bankrupt it's
because the health healthcare crisis
we're looking now at kids with health
insurance without health insurance are
less likely to go to school we look at
these these pensions that are failing
these companies these airlines and and
car manufacturers who are defaulting on
pensions or read renegotiating their
pensions and it's because of health care
every other country a developed country
has universal health care does it for
less money for about half per person and
has better outcomes we're not that much
dumber than the rest of the world that
we can't do better than we're doing now
and and one of the things that gives me
optimism I know that sounds like it's
off your question but it I'll circle
back one of the thing that gives me
optimism is that I think that the car
companies the airlines and all these
skill come their understanding they
don't want to be in the business of
health insurance they want to be in the
business of making cars plus GM fifteen
hundred dollars per car to provide
health insurance or fifty hundred
dollars more than Toyota so I think we
have to be so I think when people look
back at this decade what I'm hoping is
at the end of the decade they'll see
that Democrats took back this country
with ideas like universal health care
renewable energy an Apollo program for
new energy living wage I mean Congress
just passed itself a pay hike but won't
won't raise the minimum wage that you
know that I believe that this
administration has been so bad that it
oak that I think people's eyes will
we open and we'll reverse these stupid
tax cuts for further you know we've
never in the history of our country
before this had tax cuts during a time
of war and I asked Paul Krugman about
this he said never in the history of
civilization as far as he knows as the
civilization cut taxes during a time of
war
this guy's cut him like three times
during war
I hope this this generation or this
decade will be known as as a bad decade
for eight years and then one where there
was a resurrection London my name is
Edward McNally and I bring greetings
from my brother Terrence so you know you
were on the show freeform
in the LA recently I think you guys have
known each other for a while turns me on
but two questions quickly maybe you're
not maybe you don't but I remember
hearing on the show and you're very good
but if when that great day comes and you
are in the the junior senator from
Minnesota what committees would you like
to serve on and why and second of all if
you are a Republican who got the know
imagine yourself in your worst nightmare
Republican having nominated for
president in 1808
how would you run how would you
recommend a Republican run for president
in the 2008
what would your what would your us okay
ladies ran I love these okay the they're
two fantasy questions one is I'm the
junior senator from Minnesota and and I
am considering this and I made no secret
about it and I like I don't know if I
ever you know I I think I would love to
be on the subcommittee for permanent
investigations
[Applause]
to me the one of the great disgraces of
this Congress is their failure to do
oversight on the contracting in Iraq it
is a disgrace Harry Truman during World
War 2 was a chair to a bipartisan
committee on contracting for the war I'd
say a lot in a lot of money and a lot of
lies but he called war profiteering
treason and I think it is what was the
second question
Oh as a Republican how would I run as a
Republican if I were Republican now my
dad was a Republican until 1964 my dad
was born in 1908 he was he voted for
Dewey twice he never would correct the
our he was the Javits Republic and so
and I you know if I were running for
president in in ouais as a Republican
I'd run of like John McCain will
probably run if he gets nominated I
think he's our strongest nominee and I
think that I used to think few months
ago that they'd never nominate John
McCain because you know the right the
Christian Right really doesn't like him
because he's he doesn't like them and
has said so even though he is
conservative on social issues like like
choice and stuff like that but you know
I would run run as fast and far away
from bush as I could because by then you
know there was a new poll out that
Robert Taft I guess it's Robert Taft the
governor of you know Roberts half the
18th of Ohio the governor there his
approval rating is six point five
percent
[Laughter]
I don't think Bush will go quite that
low but I don't think that you know I
might have I think it'd be embarrassing
not to have the president show up at the
convention but I might not give him a
speaking role by Republic hi what do you
think about Bob Woodward's two-year
silence about knowing the identity of
Valerie Plame what do I think about Bob
Woodward's his silence about knowing
Valerie Plame's identity oh his silence
about someone coming forward and telling
him Valerie Plame's about him knowing
their identity first I'm sorry you know
either the sound here is such that I
can't think that he knew the identity
earlier yeah than what I said though
okay I'm sorry so that yeah but he
didn't I don't know so much about that I
mean I don't have a real strong opinion
it sounds like he should have said
something don't you think right and it
seems like these papers don't have
editorial control of their of their own
reporters I know he's some kind of
editor there but I think he should have
told his editor-in-chief and I don't
know why he didn't but you know I'm not
a huge Woodward fan myself and in a
number of ways I have a personal thing
with the Belushi book I thought that was
a disgrace because he wrote Wired and to
me it didn't capture John really at all
it was my former partner Tom Davis said
it was as if someone wrote a book about
your your yearbook at for college was
called puked
it's just who puke when they puked and
what they do to no one learned anything
or fell in love or studied dust ascii or
anything and i really didn't like that
book at all because i felt that in the
end that woodward didn't know anything
about addiction and didn't
know anything about it you know he's uh
I don't I don't know the journalistic
ethics of what he did or didn't do I
don't but I just wanted to get in that
slam how do you see the parallels now we
we thought we saw the most corrupt
administration of our lifetime I think
when Nixon was president and you had
this vast sort of conspiracy this is
worse and well this sort of I know how
you enjoy two-part question so how do
you see the comparisons between what we
thought would be the worst
administration of our lifetime worse
than say a hundred years and now it's
only a generation later and we see
something similar with a horrible war
and all the death and all the croquet
well I mean and their second board is do
you think it'll lead to bush drinking
again like you do with Nixon say it
again why will Bush start drinking again
as did Nixon Oh
okay did I think that this is the kind
of thing that's been going around that
Bush is drinking again and blah blah
blah which i think is not a productive
way to talk about the president you know
I just think he's you know maybe it's
not in recovery
now it's kind of white knuckling it you
know I mean [ __ ] it should go to the
room because he was an alcoholic Hani is
he still is you're always an alcoholic
and I just don't think he's in recovery
and I think he should go to the room and
people yeah people say to me Stuart
that's you know that's like insane you
know the president can't go to you know
a church basement say hi I'm George and
I'm an alcoholic and then you know tell
secrets because he's the president and I
think that's the reason he has to go
because you know I can just imagine
there but for the grace of God go I can
you imagine if I were president how much
stress I'd be under I mean you know I'd
be I'd be a worst president than than
him if that such a thing is possible so
it turn it in the comedy and it's not so
offensive okay a few more okay I gotta
sign books all right hey Al Franken um I
just wanted to thank you very much for
lives and the lying Liars I it seen me
through many dark nights and when nobody
else was brave enough to say anything at
all and I think that speaking out for
truth and justice is a great way of
honoring your ancestor thank you um my
my question my question is do you feel
that the two-party system is is a real
choice and how can we make that better
either in terms of quality or quantity
I'm just interested in hearing your
thoughts a two-party system is that I
think I'm a Democrat and I think that's
what we got we got two parties I think I
mean no we have any there's other
parties and then everyone welcome to
join another party and vote for Ralph
Nader and screw the pooch
which is what happened in in 2000 and I
think it was you know I went around you
know Ralph Nader had been a hero of mine
but I went around 2000 and I literally
was in Gainesville LaVette where the
university is in Florida like the
weekend before the election and I'd
always go to whenever I went to
universities I talked I'd say okay who
here's for Nader and then I talked
directly to them and say why you phonate
her and and you realize how awful Bush
will be for the reasons you're talking
and I said and I literally said this
like I think the Sunday before the
election you are going to feel so stupid
if Bush wins this election by 200 votes
you know I think we have something I
think would make two-party system
stronger would be election reform which
includes public financing of Elections
[Music]
I mean we're seeing what what money does
again I mean we're just seeing in spades
and you know you pay now as taxpayers
and to do public financing or you pay
later and when you pay later it's a lot
more money we get ripped off right and
left because of the way money is in
politics I also think it'd be nice to
have you know a paper trail and ballast
you know so people could like trust it
also be nice to have actually
nonpartisan districting so that you know
I think it and also nonpartisan you know
administration of Elections I think it's
ridiculous whether it's a Democrat or a
Republican they have the Secretary of
State of a state run the electoral
process I mean we've seen in the last
two elections how pernicious that is
there's I you know have election day on
a weekend so people can vote you know
and you know it but I I certainly
understand the impulse to one third
parties but I I'm a Democrat so go ahead
and although I would encourage very
right-wing Republicans to join the
Libertarian Party I think that's a very
and vote for them okay Franken can you
please give us your thoughts on the Bush
administration's elimination of the
roadless rule and our national forests
as well as the basic giveaway of our
natural resources in federal lands and
taking place under this administration
okay the question is about the sort of
the Interior Department and and
basically just the entire environmental
policy of this administration is
ridiculous and this is another area
where I
that there is going to there is a
consensus forming in this country about
things like global warming and about our
just our the quality of our air I was in
North Carolina today in Asheville North
Carolina and one of the things that we
do when we do our radio shows when we go
around the country we do local issues
and we had a state senator there who was
state representative when three years
ago they pass a clean smokestack law
this isn't exactly addressing your
question but the whole area of the
environment and North Carolina did it
North Carolina very red state did it as
the Bush administration was dismantling
new source review and essentially
gutting the Clean Air Act this is a
moral issue too this is about values to
protecting our being good stewards of
our earth I believe that you know I was
at a global warming conference a couple
months ago and there were a number of
religious leaders there and evangelical
groups and not liberal evangelical
groups is like you know straight ahead
evangelical group and they understood
they understand that this is about about
leaving our kids and future generations
our responsibility not to steal the
Commons and and and Bobby Kennedy speaks
so well so beautifully about this about
how you know this country is being
looted this country is being looted
and and you know and then and then their
energy policies ridiculous they're just
you know III was hoping that that you
know Bush would come out and say that
the real reason we went to a war with
Iraq oriented to you know with Saddam
was for energy but it wasn't really for
oil it was for solar energy that that
that whole region is so sunny then we're
securing you know and then and then I
think pre-emptive Wars renewable energy
could be the future so like very windy
countries could be in trouble you know
it's just another part and you know that
you know the clean the the clear skies
initiative I mean it's basically to
clear the skies of birds all I can
figure out